alright movie retrospective time yes is
going to okay cats eyes now this is one
we've mentioned this before I think we
probably mentioned it on the creep show
you know episode that we did and I think
because I mentioned it our friend Rob
who sends us lots and lots of movies
yeah sent me the blu-ray for this so I'm
really really excited about it because I
hadn't seen this movie I thought a
million times like back on cable and
then I had never seen it and I was
surprised it's kind of like going back
in time it's a good movie yeah it was
kind of like an anthology and it was
like along the lines of what you would
get back in the back in the 80s of like
the Steven Spielberg era it kind of felt
almost kind of like a Spielberg horror
movie it did because it was more like
now I should say that is this as good as
say Creepshow no I mean but how many
horror anthologies are as good as
Creepshow not that many I frankly um but
that you know that came out 82 this came
out three years later now Creepshow was
kind of more focused on like the kind of
over-the-top gore and stuff like that
stuff like that whereas this one was
rated pg-13 which in 1985 was a new
rating I think it came into like being
cuz it gremlins right yeah pg-13 back
then would have been an R today yeah it
probably will be a lot of [ __ ] we you
know that people would see today in a
pg-13 movie back from those days they'd
be like that they allowed that you know
smoking drug references I think they
even allowed certain amounts of nudity
in pg-13 they yeah because I think I've
seen some pg-13 movies from back then
that at least had like tits and yeah and
so you know it was cool we liked it well
yeah you didn't have a lot of toys back
yeah but yeah so this one came out in
1985 and it's actually three stories now
the first two stories were adaptations
of two of Stephen King's stories that
was that was in the anthology night
shift so it'll be a quitter zinc and the
ledge and then the third story which is
called general was one that he wrote
specifically for the movie now the thing
about it is that the cat there's not
really a wrap around in the sense that
Creepshow has the route
with a voodoo doll contrived yeah well
here's something that I found out when I
was like researching the movie was that
initially they did fit I believe they
did film a prologue that was like that
kind of explained you know the
relationship between the cat and Drew
Barrymore's character from the third
story who's name is Amanda and why the
cat was like traveling to find her and
like there was like a psychic link
between them or something like that but
I do feel like since that's kind of
established over the course of the movie
I don't think you really needed that you
know what I mean I think it might have
like bogged the movie down a little bit
cuz it wasn't really you figured it out
like as it went on here's the cat you
know this girl is like psychically
talking to her to the cat and the cats
trying to get to her to save her from
some calamity or whatever and that's
kind of what ties the three stories
together other than that the stories
don't really have anything to do with
one another but that's you know that's
totally fine so this was actually all of
it was written by Stephen King it was
directed by Louis Teague who also
directed Cujo and the jewel of the Nile
so and also I wanted to mention too
because I think when we were watching it
you were talking about how strange that
score was yeah it's very 80s cheesy yeah
um you know who did that Alan Silvestri
he also did Back to the Future and
predator hour Forrest Gump as a matter
of fact um it just it had kind of a
weird 80's vaporwave type of cheesy
sound like a cheesy Kassia it did yeah
but you know it fit for the time yeah
for the tone of the movie I guess you
know it's yeah this is not it this is
this is a good movie you know it's I
would say it's it's a it's way above
your average Stephen King movie your
average Stephen King movie was pretty
[ __ ] crappy this one is up there with
like you know Christine in terms of
quality yeah and I think I watched them
both right around the same time yeah
which is you know it's pretty good maybe
this one like you know but I like
Christine that's a good movie I do as
well and I and I feel like that doesn't
get a lot of
when you're talking about Stephen King
education very well yeah I think so too
yeah I think we did review it on this
channel it didn't look that good on VHS
but it looks really good on blu-ray on a
new Smart TV well everything looks
everything looks so much better but I
think a lot of I think televisions CRT
television and VHS I think that actually
tarnished a lot of movies reputations
over the years trail during the video
rental age yeah because during that time
you know some that [ __ ] didn't transfer
wrote real well and it would come across
as all that it's all low-budget cheap
asthma because it didn't look that good
yeah because it looks like crap or look
like [ __ ] but in the theater had you
seen it in the theater it looked great
yeah well now you can see the way they
used to look in the theater and this
movie looks good man's got good special
effects especially for the time good
acting yeah this really has kind of like
an all-star cast another thing I wanted
to note too and I didn't know this
either but apparently when the movie was
first being made it was produced by a
Dino De Laurentiis now before this was
made the three stories were actually
supposed to be quitters Inc was always
supposed to be the first one and then
general the one about the cat was the
cat and the troll it was always going to
be the third one
however they the middle one they weren't
gonna do the ledge they were actually
gonna do another Stephen King story
sometimes they come back if you guys
remember that one about the guy going
back to the town like the bullies that
killed his brother and [ __ ] like that
but I think that they decided the
producer Dino De Laurentiis was like
well one sometimes they come back is a
much darker story than the three that
turned up in the movie so he didn't
think it would fit in with the tone and
also he thought that sometimes they'd
come back would make a better like
feature-length movie so he did actually
make a made-for-tv adaptation of it in
1991 which I saw a long time ago and I
remember being not that bad because
that's actually like a really good short
story I think it even had I think it
even did well enough that it had like at
least one sequel maybe two but I'm you
know I'm so kind of disappointed about
what happened would do that with Dino
pictures DiLaurentis films were [ __ ]
good but they lost a lot of money yeah
making bombs they didn't look that good
on VHS it didn't really
in transfer real well and I don't you
know but they you know they looked great
in the theater I remember seeing him a
lot of them in the theater and [ __ ]
loved it man
yeah Megan like Flash Gordon flat people
made fun of the Flash Gordon movie
didn't look that good on TV but in the
theater it looked [ __ ] great yeah and
they got it on blue right now you look
at he just man it was a [ __ ]
mind-blowing movie it's comic-book movie
well it's the same with dune you know I
mean dune looked great in the theater
and it looks good on blu-ray pretty good
and this actually has a cast member from
dim the guy who plays that gangster in
the last story or the second to last
story yeah he's played that's right
Aaron harcum harcum yeah he was it a
[ __ ] ton of movies yeah and I think you
know I think Dino De Laurentiis use the
think that think that production studio
that studio you think you use a lot of
same actors well you know you can see
why they get in the habit of doing that
because you know they know he's the
known they're known quantity and it's
like you know they're gonna turn up and
do a good job and [ __ ] like that
didn't they also didn't Dino De
Laurentiis also do Conan produce did he
produce it he might have yeah was John
Miller's directing but I think that you
know that was a hit though that movie
was a [ __ ] yeah I mean he had enough
hits that people don't like remember
saying but he's he's kind of known for
funding some movies that were like you
budget failures [ __ ] up Conan - yeah
dumped that one down and made it PG for
kids and yeah it was Dino
yeah I did that they spent Dino was
known for spending a lot of money on
costumes and sets yeah but as they
started to kind of lose out he started
getting cheap you know that's what
happened with Conan - yeah but I mean
this movie
um this movie looked good I have to say
and particularly the special effects in
the third segment are like really really
good but as you said this has a much
more like playful tone I guess Creepshow
was kind of Pitt was kind of playful but
it was much more like focused on gore
and like much more horrific monster type
type of elements whereas this one is
kind of more lighthearted but then you
have like some aspects particularly in
the in the middle part like the ledge
and stuff like that where you know
there's
gangsters and beheading and things of
that nature but overall it's it's kind
of like a pg-13 movie of its err yes
much like gremlins which is like a fun
movie but then had some really fucked-up
[ __ ] tonally I thought it was kind of
similar to poltergeist one yeah kind of
like that yeah it is kind of like that
works it is there's like a lot of humor
in it and a lot of kind of like kid I
don't want to say kid-friendly but like
a kid could watch it without being
traumatized but then there's like some
kind of more adult like darker themes
come out kind of brought me back to you
know eighties suburbia yeah that feeling
that you had to be a like a Spielberg
Spielberg in a you know you know like I
said American is suck an apple pie type
you know Chevy and you know kind of you
know all-american kind of feel to it
that Spielberg had yeah back in those
days it was kind of a mainstream mall
culture feeling yeah you know what I'm
talking about yeah never I liked it
there were a lot of movies that have
this type of tone that came out around
this time period cuz like I said this
was 85 now the first it's interesting
seeing it again after so many because I
saw it like a million times when I was
growing up and I think over the years
like my favorite ones have kind of
shifted back and forth and now seeing it
again
you know that I I remember things about
you know certain ones that I like better
than the other ones and now I see it
again and I'm like oh maybe I like this
one better now I don't really know I
think probably the ledge is my favorite
for a while it was quitters Inc just
because I remember reading that story
and I liked this adaptation of it but
now I think I like the ledge slightly
better but yeah so quitters Inc is based
on like I said Stephen King short story
from nightshift which is basically about
a stop smoking clinic that really wants
you to stop smoking and they're like
using like some [ __ ] mob tactics
where it's Brisbane James Woods is in it
and he basically is like he goes to this
place because he wants to quit smoking
and he thinks they're joking at first
but apparently their whole thing is well
we're gonna be watching you all the time
and if we catch you smoke
then there's like this ramping up of
horrible [ __ ] that would have naught to
him they do it to his family they'll do
it like to his wife or his daughter or
whatever and like I said at first he
doesn't believe it it's like oh they
can't be watching me all the time but as
it goes on you find out that they're
very serious about this [ __ ] and
everything so for a long time this one
was my favorite I like and this is what
I'm saying - about like the tone being
kind of playful because this one in
particular you know James Woods is very
kind of because he's quitting smoking
and he's like really cranky and so he
has like all these funny kind of like
sarcastic lines and [ __ ] and you know
just him trying to like sneak around and
get a cigarette back getting caught and
all this other kind of [ __ ] and plus he
has that really weird like surrealist
kind of dream or whatever it is that he
has where he's like at that party and
that cover of every breath you take is
playing and like the guy from Twitter's
Inc is like there with his [ __ ]
silver jumpsuit and everybody's like
what like people are like dress if a
drop dressed up his cigarettes or
cigarette boxes and blow and smoke in
people's face and [ __ ] like that so it
has kind of like this fun like surreal
type of thing but then it has like some
kind of really [ __ ] up like
undercurrent you know what I mean so so
there was that one and then the second
one like I said watching it again I
definitely think the second one is the
best is the best one done you know what
I mean it's like it's just kind of like
because the the concept of it is like
really really simple you know Robert
Hays I think is the name of that actor
he was an airplane and he is messing
around it's you know what's weird it's
like the the kind of narrative or the
outline of this story is almost the same
as that one from Creepshow yeah you know
what I made word that we're not Leslie
Nielsen like Barry's [ __ ] you had
dancing and a beach or whatever this is
a very similar setup where you know
Robert Hayes he plays um he plays like a
tennis pro who's like [ __ ] around
with the wife of a gangster in Las Vegas
the husband fied the the gangster finds
out about it and makes a bet with this
guy that
he's like well I'll give you my wife and
a whole [ __ ] ton of money if you walk
around the ledge of my skyscraper like
evidence [ __ ] penthouse apartment and
like without falling off and because I'm
terrified of heights this one really
really scares me because pretty much the
whole bulk of it is like him just like
walking around and you like opening that
is s fall off and there's like just a
little [ __ ] like a little pigeon that
comes with pecks and [ __ ] like that and
it's like really really scary and so I
like that because it's like you know
it's just kind of like a simple story
there's not like a lot of complicating
issues it's just like a very primal kind
of like survivalists type of thing and
like I said if you're afraid of heights
like I am it's like really stressful and
the special effects in this are actually
quite good they it looks like they
probably did it with rotoscoping or
green screening or whatever it was that
they used but it actually looks pretty
damn good for like 1985 I have to say
yeah I think it's good yeah they were
above average for the time way
definitely above average oh definitely
like I said it was almost kind like
Spielberg foot yeah and then the third
one which where I think the special
effects are the best the one general
about the cat that comes with I mean the
cat finally comes and finds this little
girl who's in danger
the little gremlin troll yeah he's like
a little troll and he lives in her wall
and I like the way that Stephen King
kind of subverted because there is
actually an old wives tale about that
cats would like jump on your chest at
night and like Shakira's suck your
breath out but I like that they subvert
it it in this where it's like it wasn't
the cat doing that it was like this
little like fairy tale troll that came
out of your ball and the cat was
actually trying to save the little girl
from the troll but of course her parents
didn't believe her and was like thought
the cat was you know killing the bird
and doing all this other kind of [ __ ] in
the house when the troll was doing it
and the troll in this looks amazing I
mean just the animatronics of the face
like it has this really expressive
little face and what they did instead of
using they did use a little bit of
rotoscoping I think it's called they did
use a little bit of that like when you
know when the troll had to come up on
very mores chests and stuff but further
parts where he was just like running
around the room they put a little person
in the suit and then they built an
enormous set so it looked like he was a
little bitty troll and he was and it
looks fantastic like you would never
[ __ ] know that that was just like a
giant set like a giant bed and giant
books and everything like that yeah they
did some at work too and yeah they had
to at some points because you know there
are points where the little troll I came
up on the bed and looks real it did it's
like it really looked amazing I'm not
really entirely sure how they did that I
mean they might have had him squeezing
something and then she was like added to
it added later but it didn't look like
because a lot of times in the 80s even
in like high budget movies and this one
only cost seven million dollars even in
high budget movies you could still kind
of see the line around Lloyd you know
where it was cut off like where the
green screen was or whatever might have
been just some kind of forced
perspective yeah I'm not really sure how
they did it I don't know now that you're
thinking about cuz yes you he comes in
like squeezes or knows so she brings out
her mouth so you can like and it looked
like he grabbed it yeah it was like it
was really amazing yeah but yeah so
might have been a little puppet and the
cat that they used will actually I think
it was more than one cat I think it was
like 12 to 14 different cats they use it
for this but the cat actors in it were
actually really good getting the little
cat to chase the thing I guess they just
usually cinch it for them to do that
there were like a couple like I said
this was a not a huge box-office success
but since it only cost 7 million it made
about double its budget back so it was
seen as kind of like a modest success
also I have to mention too that this had
a whole [ __ ] ton of Easter eggs as they
didn't call them that back then but
that's what they call them now referring
to other Stephen King stories it starts
pretty much right out the gate like when
you're watching the [ __ ] credits and
then the little kitties run around and
Cujo starts chasing the kitty and then
she obviously he almost gets run over by
Christine and then there's like [ __ ]
later on like one of the characters is
like reading Pet Sematary there's like a
TV on its
it has like the dead zone that David
Cronenberg movie is on in the background
and [ __ ] so there's all the kind of like
fun there might be more than that
actually now that I'm thinking about it
like more references but it's kind of
like a fun thing if you're into Stephen
King and you can like spot all the all
the little hints and clues they put in
there like for some of his other stories
and stuff but I feel like this because
it's it didn't reach the heights of
Creepshow because I mean like Creepshow
is one of the best horror anthologies
easily top 5 horror anthologies ever
made and this only came out like a you
know two or three years later and it's
good but since it wasn't quite as good
as Creepshow I think it gets kind of
overlooked a bit and because it's not
quite as horrific it's kind of just kind
of more like a fun just kind of got
forgotten impact yeah kind of pushed to
the back but it did kind of live on in
video-rental true yeah he'd seen a
blockbuster all the time and they played
it on cable all the time which is I
think that's where I first ended up
seeing it I probably saw Creepshow first
but I did end up saying cuz I really
really liked anthology movies and you
know anything that was Stephen King
anything that was Stephen King you know
I was gonna like [ __ ] watch it it
would be like it would it would be and
like blockbusters but you know it
wouldn't be with like the big names yeah
it was always like more towards the
bottom shelves yeah it's kind of weird
where they put it
I guess because during that time a lot
of Stephen King movies kind of kind of
bad reputation people weren't retina maz
much they weren't as sought out which is
yeah it's kind of a shame because I
never hit and miss yeah because look at
like Creepshow was amazing dead zone was
amazing Carrie was amazing The Shining
was amazing yeah um but then there were
some kind of whale ears and then like
well that was later that was 90
lawnmower man he had well he sued that
his name
and I don't [ __ ] blame him because I
saw that movie and I knew at that point
like I heard about the controversy I'm
like oh I gotta see this Maximum
Overdrive is crap I don't know although
that one's actually kind of fun if
you're like drunk I haven't seen it in a
long time because it's just so big and
stupid yeah I remember it being so like
he says so [ __ ] dumb that that it's
like it's like watching wrestling yeah
you have to be in the mood for it but if
you're in the mood for it it's fun you
know what I mean cuz knows it's dumb and
then some of the television series
didn't age that well I mean I tried to
watch The Stand again and I couldn't
really get through the first episode it
was pretty but I couldn't either bad
which is a shame didn't seem to be that
bad at the time yeah it's pretty bad
Salem's Lot I think Sam's life ended up
good like you know that's pretty pretty
much the best and there were some later
ones that they made for TV which were
good like rose-red yeah that one was
really good that was probably 2000s Iowa
and I liked the television version of
The Shining a lot of people didn't like
it I don't like it I liked it that one
it was she was verbatim from the book
well yeah because Stephen King was like
well yeah
Kubrick changed it too much stuff and
he's like I'm gonna make it just like
the book and I'm like there's a reason
why you make it not just like the book
yeah it doesn't translate to the screen
very well not really no but it did
remind me of everything that happened to
them pretty much everything that
happened in the book yeah I think after
we watched it cuz we sat and watched it
one night it's like six hours long or
something and I think probably the next
day or a week later I said I'm gonna
reread the novel again you just see it's
like yeah it was like almost identical
he even like took big chunks of dialogue
and [ __ ] like that yeah I have to say
that the actors that they got for that
that wasn't who I was picturing when I
was reading the book I guess you could
redo that move that movie today we do
that entire series on make a Netflix
series out of it probably pretty good oh
no Mike you can redo it I kind of feel
like I wish umm because they've already
done it twice and I feel like you're
never gonna top Kubrick's version so
like why bother trying but I feel like
Stephen King has so many other
properties that would make good movies I
mean he has written 50 bajillion
evidently dr. sleep bombed and I like to
dr. sleep I liked it as well yeah I
thought it was a really good movie but
um I mean yeah it's a horror movies are
particularly ones like that are always
gonna be divisive yeah you know what I
mean which is kind of a shame and I can
see how old suffers in comparison with
the original shining blah blah but I you
know I liked what they did with it I
liked you know the direction they went
and I've liked a lot of the adaptations
that they made for Netflix you know what
I mean like they did [ __ ] Gerald's
game and um yeah I remember them even in
the tall grass was okay although I would
have liked it and differently I forgot
about it
yeah hit movies very pretty good the
first one was a lot better than the
second one but the second one was decent
the second was cool too was what
happened in the book though from
whatever yeah that's yeah it is it is it
stuck fairly closely and they made it
there was another one on Netflix - was
it what the [ __ ] was it there was the
one with the guy and like the well and
god damn it I can't read it was like a
year like knocking sucked ass never have
bad gunslinger was it wasn't it what was
it that wasn't even called gunslinger
was it it was called a Dark Tower like I
said and we probably talked about this
before but I was kind of like why did
they think that they could just take
that and like make it one standalone
movie never worked it didn't even really
yeah it was only kind of like
tangentially related to the books I
haven't read all the books I loved I was
first couple the fog was great now the
fog was a mess the mist yeah yeah mrs.
good that was Frank Darabont I heard
there might be thinking about making a
series about about the mist alright you
could do that because just because it
was set around a whole town so you could
kind of go into the backstories of all
the characters and [ __ ] like that whoa
no no no wait
we saw it do we see it yeah it was - it
was one season or two seasons it was all
right yeah you know I think the first
season was good and then the second
season went off the rails and I forgot
yes right yeah that was yeah we did
watch it I can't remember where we saw
it okay but yeah but so you know if
you're into Stephen King and you
especially like his eighties stuff and
like I said they made like a lot of
decent I mean yeah they made a lot of
shitty Stephen King adaptations but they
made a lot of decent one
in the 80s to like I say made Christine
they made a dead zone and this is
definitely a worthy movie and I do feel
like it gets forgotten about maybe
because it's an anthology and people are
like a creep show is kind of definitive
you know Stephen King / George Romero
type of thing and but this is like a
different thing it's it's own thing and
you know if you dig like Stephen King's
old you know old stories and you want to
see him adapted and want to see kind of
little drew Barrymore playing a whole
bunch of characters and stuff about a
hero Kitty which you know I always like
that then definitely go check it out
because I feel like it's a little bit
underrated and under seen these days so
uh yeah check it out